tomorrow Hussein hello Oscar you have
told me in the past that you are getting
a bit sick of open-world games and
they're overstuffed design yeah I think
a lot of people are feeling that
open-world fatigue yeah
often you play an open-world game and
you can see the things that are the
critical paths cream-of-the-crop things
and then there's everything around it to
distract you a lot of the time stuff
what that feels like filler yeah except
you came away from having played days
gone last week feeling a little more
encouraged about its simplicity is that
right yes I think it's really weird
because I've been trying to figure out
what it is that made it risk me respond
to it so well not so well but well and I
say well because my expectations were
really low we'd seen very little of it
friend from what we've seen so far you
saw it at e3 yeah it wasn't super
encouraging so my expectations were
quite low it's not an exceptional game
by any means it's like there's nothing
in there there's no major feature that
makes me go wow this is doing something
different or there's no element of it
that I'm like holy crap this is really
exciting like the fact that it's very
very restrained in what it does makes me
feel good like I feel like I'm not
wasting my time I'm getting the best out
of it or I'm getting the kind of cream
of the crop of what the developers
thought and I found it to be quite a
satisfying experience overall really see
that's interesting cuz when I when I
played it at e3 last year satisfying was
the exact word I would not have used all
right I I thought it it felt technically
a bit rough which of that stages is you
know forgivable because it was a few
months away but I did not find the
combat satisfying all the stealth or
basically any of its mechanics
satisfying at all hmm
but it sounds like from what you and
from what other people at GameSpot I've
said we've played it more recently it
sounds like it's improved a hell of a
lot online yeah so on the site there's a
written piece which is like a
conversation between Alessandro and Ed
and they talk about their kind of
experience for the game and one of the
things they point out which is exactly
how I feel like it feels like all the
systems are at times and it was
frequently when I played it they kind of
come together in a way that synergize is
really really well and the thing that I
liked
I'm primarily a stealth player but it
allows so I'm gonna be playing stuff as
much as I can but there are people out
there who like kind of go in and out of
difference that I also play and I think
the skirmishes and the encounters that
it sets up they allow you to do that
pretty easily the kind of feeling of the
shooting felt really really like heavy
and grounded and I really like that it
doesn't have the slickness of something
like Last of Us where you're kind of
moving between points and throwing
things to distract and that kind of
stuff it felt way more deliberate does
it feel as punchy as the last I love I
love how impactful every shot feels in
something like The Last of Us does the
stays gone feel as good as that I feel
like it has the same result but perhaps
not the same kind of like silh acceding
to it right I feel like it feels a
little more rough and tumble so like I
came we're thinking I had to like kind
of come to terms with the fact that the
rough parts might be what actually makes
it kind of interesting like it's one of
those classic double-a games from 10
years ago scenarios where it's like this
isn't as polished that's something that
no a dog would do but there still feels
like there's a lot of merit and there's
a lot of interesting things happening in
it so like that element of going into an
encampment are you silently taking out a
few people accidentally getting caught
and then just going I'm gonna switch to
my assault rifle and just go nuts here
then like I could do that take out a few
enemies then retreat into some grass and
then go back into the stealth mode and
it felt really good doing that
shooting assault rifles again is is it
felt heavy and punchy but almost bassy
like they've done sound really well here
as it seems like that's improved the
hell of a lot since I saw it yeah yeah
so it didn't sound as good at e3 but now
is it does feel really sound a lot more
punch yeah I mean it's a preview safe so
everything I say comes with a caveat
that it's a slice of the game yeah but
like one of the things I really loved
was I don't think there was a single
weapon in that game that I used that
made me feel powerful it felt like I
need to be very careful I need to be in
the right distance so that I'm landing
as many shots as possible
I need to make this quick otherwise to
zombies they're gonna find me all the
free cos they're gonna find me yeah oh
yeah they're not zombies so they're
called free cuz I think they like melded
with had some plant-based accident and
and now everyone is like weird zombie
types but it's like you get what's
interesting you get normal frequency are
dumb as hell you can come up behind them
stab them and then they're king take
them out but then you get like these
hordes which are really really really
difficult to approach so this is the
thing that I this is one thing I didn't
like when I played it was that it felt
like every combat encounter descended
into the same pattern of me running
around for like 10 minutes on end with a
million zombies chasing you and it would
just be like I'd run for 30 seconds turn
around get a few shots off then they
would have caught up sort about to turn
again keep running do that for another
10 minutes I mean it descended into the
same pattern every time I think and it
wasn't satisfying but has that change
it's still like that but I think the the
the way I don't know what section you
style but because I started off from
basically the start of the game the
introduction to those hordes of zombies
was a little more natural so I think the
game warns you pretty well like don't
screw these guys they will take you out
and also the other thing is like it's
it's the bike is a big part of the game
I was gonna ask about the bike
yes it seems like that really is your
life line and your life and soul and
yeah I don't know I feel like it's been
under sold a little bit but that to me
could
be the selling point for this game even
if is satisfying enough the problem is
it's still just a bike I am worried
about the way I say this but like for
some people bike culture is really cool
but like for a lot of people when when
this character Deacon st. John's like
treating his bike as if it's a living
child or something yeah I'm just like
this is a bit weird man let's see what I
can do
the bike is good buy it so it could be
the big thing it is definitely
interesting in that it let's it's the
main way that you move around the world
there are fast travel points but it's
fun to drive around the world if only
because you get like a tour of the what
this and all their scenes and that kind
of stuff and but the other thing I
really like is like there's random
ambushes to the world like we haven't
started it kind of feels like Far Cry 2
like I think you might dig it because
like it has that unexpected element
occasionally you'll be driving and then
you notice our crap I'm about to be
ambushed either obviously because
there's a roadblock or like they'll just
come out of nowhere and start firing at
you and you have to deal with that and
that's a really interesting mechanic
that kind of keeps you on edge the
entire time and you get you get it to
like upgrade that bike and because you
start off with a very very like the bike
gets I don't know if this is a spoiler
actually the bike gets like Metroid it's
like you've got all powerful bike but
now you've got rubbish bike you got a
bicycle yeah you've got one of those one
foot scooters you build that bike up and
you do that by going to camps and taking
out missions for people and there are
loads of characters I think I described
at our state of decays focus on
characters mixed with Far Cry is kind of
open world but pulls it back a bit and I
think that's a really good way of coming
at the the characters you speak to in
camps are generally interesting they've
been through some stuff this takes place
sometime after the apocalypse happened
say you do get a nice mixture of like
often world activities and also
characterization that could go places
there's a bunch of concurrent storylines
the one thing that I'll point out is
like deacon seems to be interesting
character but he goes from 0 to 100 like
at the site of a zombie and he is very
angry as
like it's really off-putting how quickly
he goes from zero to I'm gonna murder
every zombie in the world but I've
always liked that it seems like there's
an interesting story there that the
thing that freaks me out not freaks me
out but like confuses me or catches me
off guard is the the groundedness of it
like it has that Sons of Anarchy style
thing where you're like just in this
this open area open world and you're in
it for long enough doing things that are
normal not normal but like doing things
that are not weird long enough for you
to forget that there's zombies around
some right and then you'll turn it off
you're like oh you need to do some mad
zombie [ __ ] and you're like oh crap I
forgot that was happening yeah so in
summary then it sounds like you're
feeling cautiously optimistic is that is
that a fair summary of your feelings on
days gone so far yeah like returning to
the thing that's in our sight at the
start there's nothing that I think is
blowing me away about it but I don't
think every game needs to have that like
it would be great if it did but this is
one of those games where I feel a bit
tired by and kind of worn out by these
overstuffed and all over designed as we
sort of start open-world games like I
love spider-man but it was a whole lot
of collectibles that didn't need to be
there yeah I love Far Cry but there's so
many missions that can be caught Red
Dead like there's a lot of stuff that
could have been made easier like the
traversal getting to things I loved that
game but there's elements of it that
could have been cut so this is like it
feels like a described it as a no frills
the open-world experience and that's
kind of exciting to me because you get
what is effectively the cream of the
crop from the developers perspective
they're not putting in any like extra
fat in hair and you get to do you still
get that sensation of like being given a
task taking that task off seeing growth
in your character so that's what's
exciting me about it I'm looking forward
to kind of digging into the world and
being able to play stealth in this
zombie game that has also got a bike
yeah alright well for more on Days gone
including a preview from fellow
freaker's Alessandro and Ed's head over
to games.com
[Music]
you